are you doing alright wait I do good
Wow hey what's going on everybody first
we feast I'm Sean Evans you're watching
hot ones it's a show us how it questions
even hotter wings and today I'm joined
by Tom Arnold known from his decades and
stand-up TV films and you can catch him
on his podcast Tom Arnold 100% honest
pretty much Tom welcome to the show it's
good to be here the horrible mistake
that's good to be here how are you
without food at a situation where swim
to LA to be a rider in 88 they're this
big spread for us with sushi which I've
never eaten and but they had chips too
so I was eating chips and I saw a big
bowl of guacamole so we loaded up that's
just about third chip in I realized
that's not walkable habit eating that is
that hot stuff that goes with sushi
what's that green stuff called
you're eating what's up yeah yeah and
then it did sup to the inside of my
mouth and like since that I have been a
healthy hot stuff at all and I also have
very bad allergies so I figure I'm going
to cure by allergies by doing this today
same way I cured my bulging disc by
bungee jumping how did that work out I
ended up in the hospital yes really
[Music]
[Music]
all right so the first one sriracha
Sarat right here Oh big deal well
tobacco and ham Tom alright so I want to
start actually by taking it back to your
rooms in Iowa where you worked on the
kill floor to Hormel right meatpacking
plant you know you got to make your own
fun in there otherwise it's a pretty sad
situation pretty desperate doing stuff
like eating contests or eating hot stuff
or bread building people which is you
dip my hand bone and blood and then
little wore white uniforms and then you
go up the crack of somebody's ass put a
red thing up there and then you were
also a bouncer at the University of Iowa
yeah right yeah yeah yeah what was your
move if you discovered a fake ID with
mistletoes a boy or girl
what if it was a girl there in also we
fight the football players who are huge
300-pound guys and in Iowa who's big on
wrestling there be 100 flow pal guys you
could kick our asses yeah you got to be
care about if they can ship oh my god
where they can take ya underestimated
like a 300-pound guy you kids hit you in
the knees you get it but those little
wrestlers and I'll tell you watch for
their ears so their ears are all [ __ ]
up you know don't mess with don't mess
with them and first flooding soon why do
you think Shaquille O'Neal called you
the worst neighbor in Beverly Hills
history I think he was figured a joke
because I know he loved me it was so
exciting way to play for the Lakers you
know because I did a homeowner's
association you could have anything
different in Erie already so we had a
big Superman like there was two stories
tall nobody else could have that and
growing up in Iowa when their team
played it you know the neighborhood
would come out into the street and
celebrate but here the Beverly Hills you
don't even know your neighbors but with
a Laker played with shackles live is
there man we came out into the street it
just was that feeling he had a small
town you know it was important and I
love them
it's hot so True Lies is one of these
movies that has an enormous wave and pop
culture and I've never done the real
deep dives like some of the die-hard
fans even though I am a fan of the movie
so while I have you here yeah I want to
bounce some of the True Lies folklore
out of you and you can tell me if it's
fact or fiction does that sound good yes
sir
true or false there are jokes that are
written into the script that were
inspired by your divorce yes I would
ad-lib for instance I came to work one
day and the ice cube trays were missing
out of the freezer like and I said to
Jim Cameron what kind of a sick [ __ ]
takes to [ __ ] an ice cube trays out of
the freezer well who tastes like that
and he's like you just say that in the
movie today because I mean who thinks
that little like women are so much
smarter they think of the little the
little digs
Arnold almost died during the horse
scene is that true or false it's true
that was awesome but you know wanted it
to look real so instead of the stunt man
he want to ride it we're shooting in a
park in Georgetown you know there by
Washington DC I can see that horse was
done being ridden and so it stopped and
he went over the front and it was the
funniest thing ever no one wanted to
capped you except for James camp right
that sure absolutely true and when he
told Fox because it was the most
expensive movie ever made time great
news wife out of the third guy after
Jamie Lee and Arnold we can start
filming True Lies but I got fantastic
news Jim who is it he said it's Tom
Arnold they're like that's terrible news
and he said why they say don't read the
tabloids he's a crazy person he said no
I don't read the tabloids but I wrote
this movie he's the guy and they're like
well we can't approve Tom armed for this
movie and Jim Cameron said that's too
bad because I really wanted to make the
movie here at Fox now I'm going to walk
across the bucket street and make it a
Paramount and they were like okay we'll
give him a chance so but I didn't know
so every day when the Fox guys came to
the set I was like high-fiving them for
you know loving me and they hated me
oh really inhaling those wings tongue
well I could eat very fast very fast mmm
so you co-starred in exit wounds with a
couple guys who've inspired tons of
stand-up material nothing Steven Seagal
now India Magnum the antics of both have
become kind of folklore both for movie
buffs and hip hop fans you know for
someone who experienced it firsthand
what was it like when those two
interacted well my trailer was in
between those two
they weren't pals or anything you know
the one thing I seriously call a little
- they bought him a $70,000 wig which
I'd be honored but he is too much pride
to wear up so he colored his hair with a
black sharpie one time we had a
houseboat and there's a door here and a
door here you pull up to the dock either
side and he argued with the drinker so
long about not wanting to rehearse
because that's this thing I don't
rehearse man I don't anyway bye Jerry
said roll camera and he got up to leave
it he's supposed to walk out this door
to the docks but he forgotten which side
was the doctor which side was the ocean
and being at the Anderson sitting right
there
and I saw him say I'm going to go to
town and kill your whole [ __ ] family
and then he doesn't go this way he goes
that way that day you wake up
oh [ __ ] so I look at Anthony I go check
tell him he's on his own okay all this
door takes a step and bam he's gone in
the ocean and I see I swear
black sharpie had come to the surface
and then I had to fish him out and man
he was wet any of that muumuu and he was
so high to get at the Edison to help a
fish about his life basically whose
extra-heavy
all right so every week we do a second
on the show called explain that Graham
and what we do is we do a deep dive on
our guest Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context for Tom
Arnold we've pulled out some iconic Tom
Arnold throwbacks so I'll just show you
the picture and you tell me the bigger
center here that sounds ok how you doing
Tom I'll get up uh-huh all right first
one you and Chris Farley I got stage at
Woodstock yes
Woodstock Danny for need Chris Farley
this man my wedding we got the wood
Socrates like I'm not going on stage
though to get paid all the sudden I go
nobody's getting paid to emcee he called
his manager he's being a dick about it
and I introduced him and I go ladies
gentlemen Arnold Schwarzenegger the
crowd goes crazy gives us 94 and then
Chris comes out as somebody hits him in
the face with a claw tub of grass this
big it was an Arnold orgy later though
that was payback but I love the guy here
you are locking jack game with Adrienne
that's our all-star that's our outfield
I was the MVP of that game by the way
but had to take something so special
about that was there's this little kid
on the side they wanted to play in the
game he had a giant glob little kid
about this big you know and they would
lie said let him play the last out than
the mtv3 were like no way the poor
little kid so I put him in it on my own
and he caught the last out this little
kid with his big old glove and turn out
to be Prince Fielder dad sessile was
played in that game
and he turns into being this great
professional baseball player but he was
a little little boy then with a giant
glove shot on Prince Fielder I think
he's actually a hot one fan I bet he's
going to see that oh yeah I like him a
lot you know I like him a lot because
he's an athlete and he is very big but
if I bet if you saw him naked you go
he's not fat as I thought it would be
all right so this next one is ghost
pepper and blueberry and Eskimo blue I
bet it's really heavy on the blueberry
no oh my god
of all the athletes that you've worked
with who do you think has the best TV
personality
Oh Michael Strahan I knew that when he
was a rookie he was going to be doing
things beyond football Michael Irvin's
also go to Michael Arvid was our
football guy and they always say do not
talk about getting arrested with hookers
or cocaine and that and we start to show
to go okay I got arrested with hookers
and I did cocaine and I gotta admit it
was pretty fun I don't do it anymore
whatever he said not to say he would say
that's good though you get out I loved
him I loved him or they say to me where
you do don't mention Jerry Jones face
look because you can't bad-mouthing me I
felt the first thing I say did you know
did you know Jerry Jones had a facelift
he's like yeah a dog he's got a facelift
I love that show and the people start on
that show done fantastic
[Music]
so people eat just to enjoy it
I don't know write this off yeah yeah
sorry little just burn on the outside of
my life but this is it and it's up
dimmer so I want to go from an on-air
gag probably the realest thing I've ever
seen you on TV and that is when you went
to the Comedy Central Roast of your
ex-wife Roseanne and actually cooked her
on the roast right the week of we get a
call well she wants to dress up like a
waiter server drink during the show and
that's it I really well I would have
told her that's stupid and she was at
Bucky what I would [ __ ] you and that was
in the end of it and it wouldn't happen
it's a good thing if she I didn't take
your call Wednesday actually now she
wants me to come out and make fun of the
other people on the dais turn to her
give her a fist bump and then leave and
I said oh so I come to the rose and Rose
Tom Arnold right I don't address her
right I address these other [ __ ] and
they're like yeah it'll be great I go
that's stupid and people will be pissed
I'm not doing that and I'm glad she call
Kubota Thursday like anything you want
and so I call my lawyer deal solution we
got restraining orders against both of
you we got this thing your divorce so
complicated if she says stuff about your
penis then she owes you a hundred grand
if you say something Regina you owe her
undergrad anyway
but that was it it went as well as it
could go
that's all I'm gonna say I think I
touched my eye not after I touch this
okay by this side here okay
oh that's why I know the bed move okay
let's keep going
so the next one is the bomb
yeah ready yeah yeah all right honey one
Oh God
why do people which is just very
athletic yeah
so no an apology on social media knows
that you take great pride in being a
father and I've heard you talk about how
you saw your son Jack peeing in the
front yard after he saw you peeing in
the marred besides the obvious like
swearing what are some other behaviors
that you don't even know are abhorrent
until you see them reflected in your
children you know yelling at people I
got into a big argument on the street
with somebody that's okay that's what
that this is real yeah it's not a joke
just like Bear Grylls like you don't
think it's going to be right hell yeah
they have bear ghosts real what a trait
that you hope that your kids get from
you and what's one that you hope skips a
generation
Wow
uh compassion and everything else how
Elvis goes to generation
is it better to prepare your kids for
what they'll find on the internet or to
just let them discover it themselves you
just try to protect them these are very
smart
one-side witty witty bus couldn't figure
out my password I didn't do it it opens
up pornhub this is laughing a low-key
app step mother horse and that's when I
realized I got to protect my kids better
for myself wheels coming off a little
bit yeah alright this is mad dog 357
[Music]
okay so I know they got healthy a few
years back and that you've lost 100
pounds you have the birth of your son
but I do want to talk to you about the
food in Iowa because it's amazing so
what I'll do here is bounce some Iowa
foodstuffs off of you and you can just
tell me the first thing that comes to
your mind okay
yeah loose meat sandwiches awesome the
canteen in Ottumwa Iowa the best loose
beef sandwich to the world kind of place
where they tried to tear down to build a
parking ramp who wouldn't let him at the
middle around them
taco pizza oh happy Joe's best of the
world what's the weirdest things you
have to eat at the Iowa State Fair well
you know there's great things like pork
chops on stigma
fried stickers pretty weird ready to
move on Tom yeah glasses fogging up a
little bit so before you use the wing
Tom this is Blair's Megadeth song with
liquid rage it's tradition around here
to put a little extra dab on the last
wing don't have to if you don't know if
you Tom I don't want to peer pressure
you just do a river whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
Tom yeah that's file let's switch
okay okay same guitar hey all right down
got it
so in hammer Tom so you said that
appearing on that Australian reality I
know I'm a celebrity get me out of here
alone horrible experience that you had
but I have to imagine that now you just
ate a winged out if there's mega desktop
of liquid rage that you might be
rethinking that a little bit yeah
so what I want to do is found what has
to be the most horrible experiences off
of you again and you can tell me which
one is the worst
okay going through a tabloid divorce
appearing on a hot one yeah the people
who tell us that you need to put up or
shut up with those damn celebrity
apprentice Trump tapes ah is the word I
think the Trump tapes re-explaining I
can't because I want to cost
there's better tapes out there that
leads to rush out there's there's a head
game with this Bobeck example a worse
physically than any of those because
Lisa Trump page I know how it turns out
and this Haley the celebrity dewater I
know the end oh well I might how this
turns out oh I'm not sure if I live or
die
well you know what if you live or if you
die you'll be remembered as a legend Tom
Arnold maybe I made it through a few
clear at the board 10 wings up ten wings
down you look terrific
yeah beuliss camera this camera or this
camera those that people know what you
have going on in your life Thanks
podcast Tom Arnold everything on very
bad I can't watch
you're supposed to help go up a little I
got a movie out alkyl add like a [ __ ]
from Wrigley for the mouth who gives a
[ __ ] what's going on
[Music]
I doing our actuate a new great [ __ ]
you brought your own bandana prepared
hey what's going on hot ones fans if you
liked the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you liked the video subscribe thank you
very much I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend